[Music]
jason kenny is trying to keep his
political career alive
on thursday brian gene the man who lost
to kenny in the united conservative
party's first leadership race was sworn
back into the alberta legislature he won
a by-election last month and his
intentions now are pretty clear we know
that we have some very serious issues
the most important being the ndp in the
next election is going to get an
overwhelming majority if we keep the
same leader brian gene and former
alberta opposition leader danielle smith
have both declared they'll run to lead
the ucp before jason kenny's leadership
review has even taken place they're both
raising rural issues
they're both raising uh covet
restrictions issues
so that is clearly the the challenge
that kenny is looking at but there's a
lot of moderates in the party who have
also been upset with jason kennedy's
approach frustration with kenny could be
why interest in this leadership review
is so high what began as an in-person
agm with a couple of thousand people
turned into a virtual mail-in ballot
contest after the expected attendance
swelled to more than 15 thousand there's
been
a lot of
unhappiness on the part of the rebels in
the party about a mail-in ballot
i think because they are concerned that
this is
much easier to manipulate the rcmp is
still investigating allegations of voter
fraud related to the last ucp leadership
contest in 2017
[Applause]
kenny has spent recent weeks positioning
himself as the moderate choice for
albertans a winner who will lead the ucp
to another mandate the party now facing
big decisions with little time to waste
a provincial election against a popular
and familiar opposition just one year
away
heather urex west global news calgary